Let's go to our caller from the three 47 area
code caller from three, four, seven.
Go ahead.
Hello.
Is that Nick?
Yes, it is.
Hi.
Uh, I was just wondering because yesterday
Nancy Pelosi had a, she ripped up the speech,
right?
And it was like the big dramatic thing, right?
Yeah.
So she wraps up the speech, right?
But she's signs like all these kind of detrimental
bills such as Trump's military budget, the
extra ice funding.
So I was wondering if it kind of shows like
a kind of facade that the democratic party
kind of puts out towards like, I dunno like
the people or whatever, but rips up his speech
that doesn't really do much.
You're completely right.
I mean, listen, I said in my end now, the
day after the speech, I said in my analysis
on the show, I found it hilarious when she
ripped up the speech.
It's a really funny reality show thing to
do to a reality show president.
Like the entire state of the union was a reality
show.
It was a, you know, and your husband's not
really in Afghanistan.
He's right here.
Come on down.
And then like I have a surprise for you rush.
I'm giving you the congression, you know,
the presidential, it was all a reality show
and Nancy Pelosi capping it by ripping up
the, is a hilarious part of the reality show
now to get serious.
You're completely right, which is she, it's
the aesthetic of resistance, but it's like
she's signing off on a whole bunch of the
stuff that Trump is doing.
So in that sense, she's just a part of the
reality show the way Trump is.
Right?
Yeah.
So like my other question regarding that right
is for the extra ice funding and everything
are these like, cause I'm just wondering,
are these um, ways to get democratic bills
passed but to let Republicans get like whatever
deal that they want?
There's no, there's no blanket answer to that.
There's no blank.
I mean, of course there are times when Democrats
will vote for something they don't really,
they wouldn't propose because it's coming
as part of a compromise, but it, you know,
you have to look at the specifics of it.
There's no way to just blanket say yes or
that's yes or no.
That's why Pelosi is doing some of those votes.
All right.
Thank you so much for the call.
I love you David Pacman.
All right, appreciate the phone call.
Thank you so much.
Great to hear from you.